are you ready for the next hearthstone
expansion you don't have to wait long
I'm Tony this is a game spot news update
and to keep up with all the newest
content for your favorite games be sure
to subscribe journey to on goro brings
135 new cards to heart stone and we've
gotten a peek at a few already like the
volcano and the Pyro's a new adapt
keyword is also being introduced which
will let you buff a minion with one of
10 total bonuses but the biggest new
addition is the quest card type these
will always show up in your opening hand
and if you complete the task it assigns
you'll get a huge boost for that match
journey to on goro releases this April
but you can pre-order 50 card packs for
50 bucks right now we're certainly fans
a blizzard here at gamespot and you can
hear us discuss all the best game
developers on the lobby our live show
every wednesday at 11am pacific for all
the latest song hearthstone and other
Blizzard games you're already in the
right place
you